a major milestone for a clark county
school district
a capella group 8 news now reporter
kristen drummond shows us how the
students are staying pitch perfect
even during the pandemic this is a story
that i have never told singing together
while apart
the pandemic does not stop the music for
green envy
it's envy like nevada the co-ed a
cappella group at green valley high
school
and it's always been like a family and
that's something that we pride ourselves
on
[Music]
after forming nearly a decade ago the
students finally achieved qualifying for
the international championship of high
school acapella
it's like the competition seen in the
2012 movie pitch perfect
[Music]
but for high schoolers when the group
first started
they they said it was one of their goals
to try to get into the
competition
[Music]
leading the vocalist our seniors strad
slater and molly martin the student
directors guide their peers
after making it to the quarterfinals we
have worked our butts off to get to
where we are
part of that work includes submitting a
performance for the judges
showcasing not just singing but video
producing
and editing skills green envy set
features two songs
warrior by demi lovato
and i'm still standing by elton john
kim ritzer supervises the group and says
the vocalist aim to tell
a story during warrior they started
black and white and then they it
eventually goes into color
and it shows things life events that
changed kids lives
the pandemic also creating an
opportunity for them to sing in the
contest for the first time ever
because it's online for one thing people
just can't
some people just can't travel depending
on like what school you're in or like
you know finances and stuff
overcoming challenges to show how
they're awka awesome
kristen drummond 8 news now
we can also tell you that the
quarterfinals will be live streamed this
friday online
and we do have a link if you'd like to
check it out on our website at
8newsnow.com